all right guys what's up it's me
Kate yes we're back on camera people
keep a messaging me I want to say to the
people watching on YouTube that a lot of
you guys message me in my DMS on
Instagram which by the way I do read so
even if I don't write to back I do read
them I just don't always hit allow
because once I hit allow then some
people will keep writing and writing and
writing and writing and I feel guilty to
not reply but I want you to know I do
read the DMS and a lot of you are like
what happened to date fails because we
haven't been on camera in a few weeks
because when I'm on the road I've been
doing this in my hotel room so what I'm
trying to say is if you can't see it on
YouTube you can listen to it on iTunes
SoundCloud stitch or all things comedies
website so make sure you guys to listen
and I'll try to start recording at my
hotel room but sometimes you know we
record it naked and as much as you would
like that I I would not like that to be
understood not yet not for free but
anyway with that said I'm super excited
to be back in the studio I miss Aaron my
producer Aaron have you been well is
your mic on I hate to make you yes I've
been I've been very well even have you
been doing softball and all kinds of fun
things oh yeah how's the wife great
Aaron's the only person I know in a
successful relationship I don't know I
don't know why we don't talk more
grilling like he managed to do it he
found love he yeah he could drop serious
knowledge so anyways guys I was in Vegas
all last week I did an episode of this
in Vegas of Brian monarchy at a crazy
week in Vegas it was great and now I'm
back in LA and I got my homies in the
studio today both you guys are so dope
thank you for being here first of all I
got my buddy comedian Jack at the Dorian
Jun yeah jr. comrade oh my god I'm so
happy you're here and Jack is coming
with me to Phoenix to play the house a
comedy he's going to feature there for
me when is it it's the third weekend in
August the last 25th to the 28th yes
that's correct
it I don't know it's in August guys
Wednesday through Sunday I'm glad that
you know and I know that's good I'm
excited
I wanted to organize Omicron it's gonna
be hot spots all over there tennis
courts at that condo I don't know play
tennis I know I'm going to teach you 120
degrees and I'm going to pump you full
of adderall and hand you a tennis racket
right because that's how I do it kind of
weight that way your heart's gonna
explode
don't you find you have lost weight you
were to saw he just said I look like
I've lost weight which I guess you lost
weight i toned up a little I got had to
drop a little weight for this photo
shoot at the Chive and I actually I
think I got to I got a little to fit I
didn't like it I looked like one of
those marathon runners no offense to the
marathon runners are like I was like the
girl boy yeah like I have I have an aunt
who runs marathons and God bless her
she's an incredible shape but I mean
like she's like 50 and she's like all
mouth shut Knorr yeah Chuck Norris with
ten yeah so I don't know I when I start
to get a little too buff I I don't like
that I like to be just a little just a
little song meeting yeah keep your like
feminine yeah but you look like you've
dropped away I did I'm started taking
those a decision the true story you know
Facebook cause like he's actually well
had an anchor from those thirty pounds
per Baywatch I clicked it and then they
sent me these pills I just started
taking them they're like diet pills you
don't even know what they are and I
decided to I mean are they I do cocaine
I got candy worse than that we that's a
great a great topic to bring up because
today's sponsor the health food book
isn't it yeah but that's okay I mean
everybody in this town has done a little
bit of something and then I have Cheryl
you look stunning today it doesn't sure
caught it right you're so pretty like it
weighs a little ooh yeah
she is the moon no you look gorgeous
so you've been on here before you're an
amazing social media person you have
hilarious videos on your Instagram which
I think they're getting funnier all the
time oh yes the goal is funnier all the
time actress and social media Queen
charelle Patrice
I don't go back what's new with you just
grind and shoot and everything I mean
I'm approaching 100,000 followers on
Instagram I'm winging aggressively
fighting to break into that like here I
know I know
isn't it funny I'm trying to get to
100,000 too but then I feel like now a
million is the new hundred thousand like
it doesn't even feel like a hundred
thousand is anything in Japan so many
people that are like kind of in the LA
genre of comedy and stuff that are now
having these high followings and so it's
like oh okay I guess I'm like once I had
100 I'm like okay now I gotta work
towards a million you know what you have
to do you know what you have to do the
other day I was at tennis okay I'm a
tennis the other day and just for fun I
was like you know I want to make a video
where it's like I'm peeing in the middle
of the tennis court but like like I want
to make a video says P like no one is
watching like dance like no one is
watching but it's peeing and I'm peeing
in the middle of the tennis court but
then like the camera pans back and
there's two guys playing on the court
next to us and I decide so I did it and
it's really funny I didn't I didn't pee
for real I used a water bottle but you
can't see it in the video so but you can
see my but like my butts out so I'm like
squatting with my butt out I pretend to
pee Jackson McQueen was with me and then
he pans back you know and then it shows
the two guys playing tennis and I'm like
these guys are pretty good
they're like totally you know it was
like very chill did you hosiah
yeah I posted this video yeah it turned
out really funny but but so that video
got me a thousand Instagram followers
that was one video yes and me I do bare
ass my bare ass is that and then I
didn't realize I didn't do it to be
sexual on purpose I mean of course bare
ass is but I thought it would be funny
and kind of like maybe a little hot but
what I didn't think about is you know
how girls drip-dry if there's no toilet
paper someone I did the drip dry I was
like I got a drip dry and I kind of like
bounce oh that's what got the views when
I watched it was
yeah so but what but the reason I bring
it up is because I just think it's
hilarious how seriously people take
things on social media I mean I got it
got 60,000 views I got like two thousand
likes and actually Bert Kreischer regram
dit for me which was so sweet like I
love this yeah but then I got like 50 or
60 people commenting like this is
disgusting you're a dirty [ __ ] why
would you pee on a 10-2 people are trash
or white trash and I was like one it's a
joke too
I mean I didn't pee on the tennis court
but even if I did own the [ __ ] down it's
pee like yeah like I [ __ ] like came
your mom's house and pissed on her face
like it's a what she might be into by
the way but anyway I just thought it was
so funny how personally people take
things have you ever posted something on
social media that people get really
upset about are you happy you like it
again so family no need you leave the
mean Colin oh yeah what'd you do I
delete mean comments and block people I
love talking people that is like Halle
love you guys blogs I have at least 200
people really I only blocked my baby
mama not you have your baby mamas laws
on every line in life ha ha that's
hilarious
isn't see anything honestly though why
she's I just want to follow you to see
like what I like seeing her son I mean
you know you want to see her on that and
still you guys have never you guys have
been broken up since he was born right
yeah
Wow and he's he's had a birthday
yesterday years old I show up at the
haha last night which by the way your
show was awesome it was so fun jack has
an awesome show it's a haha comedy club
Wednesday nights and I show up there and
Jack's drinking tequila shots he goes
have a shot we're celebrating a birthday
I'm like whose birthdays like my kid
he's not here I'm like any reason to
celebrate
yeah have you ever posted something that
like you got tons of negative comments
oh yeah
I've had several like viral videos that
typically any of my viral videos
typically like pissed someone off so
I've had numerous videos where people
get upset over things like I had one I
posted actually like a couple weeks back
or whatnot and it had like a little in
the beginning of the video someone takes
someone's wallet and it was like I like
a white black thing or whatever and so
people started getting offended by that
and like I don't know I just had stuff I
mean I've also done stuff as a woman
where I was dressed in an outfit and it
was basically when I walk past some guys
and I like I'm like oh you guys are so
thirsty but I'm like in a bra and like a
short short right right and so then they
like Heil me with water bottles and like
I fall into a car and so then people
like women got upset and they were like
women should be able to dress any type
of way like I can't believe you do this
it's crazy like but like being in comedy
I kind of feel like sometimes you've got
to offend people and it is what it is
I'm not doing anything where I'm like
praising anything that's like racist or
homophobic or sexist it is like everyone
who those people that have it stick up
their butt and they're going to be upset
regardless yeah they met about anything
they're men about their lives and they
go I'm gonna bring everyone down right
you know someone told me a story last
night actually and I don't know if it's
exactly true but it's hilarious about
Joe Rogan because they were saying that
they heard Joe Rogan I don't know if
he's giving an interview or what it was
on he was talking about arguing back and
forth with some Twitter troll some guy
was being a dick to him and they were
arguing back and forth and then you know
at one point Rogan said like all right
ma'am well I've done all these things in
my life what have you done and he was
like not much yet I'm 13 and it's like
it that's the reality is like you know
when you're arguing with RINO I thought
guys do that on mine and they'll be like
you're a you're a [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
I'll go look at their page and they're
like 12 years old like what are you
gonna do yeah and at the time I suppose
going to Instagram like hassles people
that write comments they have private
pages yeah like you can't even go on
their page I'm gonna be paying to talk
[ __ ] moment I'm your pain I go on your
face you gotta make a fake profile 14
you're 12
exactly it's so true
well man are so many things I want to
talk about today I mean like it's it's
funny I have so many good stories
recently one thing I want to talk about
we're talking about weight loss and I
was thinking on the way here I've been
hanging out with this guy and he's
become a vegan since I met him and I've
never dated a vegan because I won't
because I'm like they're always tired my
benefit I feel like I feel like if
you're a vegan like I don't know I feel
like you won't last in bed and you won't
keep up with me anywhere you're gonna
like see now yeah it's not like
patchouli and dress like you're [ __ ]
on your way to like some music festival
all the time so but so I start dating
this guy but then we'll go out to eat
places and I don't want anything yeah I
want me usually have a couple days all
vegan cooking what the hell the reason
why yeah I've had vegan cookies and
confession I've actually been not eating
meat the past month and a half the hell
out of vegetarian is different from be
good
but at this past week I'm trying to
switch over to like cutting out like
eating v/o you're gonna mind why we're
going to lose those curves no this
genetics like even if I prove it let me
see your mouth I got submit to that
being a vegan that's a good way to lose
weight because a lot of vegan food to
supplement the protein like the protein
they eat is a lot of carbs and more
calories wanna know that is sure I mean
there is unhealthy but for me I was just
trying to eat healthier so I chose to
cut out meat I stopped drinking as well
so I was like making a very strategic
thing to just eat more plant-based foods
yeah but I'm not eating like bread
instead of like I'm just eating like
actual plant you can see one question
what are you doing for fun then it can't
be good
no it is like you're not drinking you're
not eating you're not going to okay a
day consists of drinking or eating so I
think I think you want to date I'm gonna
give you a carrot
like here you go I mean I would still
like like prior to this week I was
eating seafood so I could still I mean
I'd be expose of day because I'm you
were eating trash so I was eating fish
up until this week I just was switching
over to try to like just kind of
jumpstart something make a decision I'm
down yeah yeah I think fishes I don't
know I was trying to tell this dude I
mean can you just eat at least eat fish
so we can still do sir because that's a
thing so we keep going to be good places
and I don't eat soy if I can avoid it
because it just it makes it gives me
like a upset stomach so now we're going
to these vegan places most the time all
the the protein is like soy like orange
so I don't want to eat so I was thinking
on the way here like man this is the
best way to lose weight it's a data
vegan because I want to eat [ __ ]
anywhere they take core and if you do
eat it tastes so bad you might throw it
up so basically in the end you're just
getting to drop tons away I hate when
you go to even a restaurant that they go
ok the compound chicken and it's not
about chicken it's their version of it
and then they go what kind of protein
did you like I'm like meat that just
happened to me another guy that I was
dating I didn't even know he was like an
undercover vegan not even worse at least
this guy like admits it I was dating
this other guy took me to this
restaurant I didn't know it was a vegan
restaurant and I ordered the ceviche and
I'm eating I'm like why is that it
seafood chewy it wasn't real serious
vegan SBJ I've also tried I could do
that too oh I don't care about that cuz
I'm not paying
I think there's that I'm like normally I
would chip in at some point but I'm like
if we are taking me it's a place I don't
want to eat I'm not bad well I think
there should be compromised because I
especially like now that I've switched
kind of dietary things and I still
haven't a family of people that eat
[ __ ] chicken wings all the time like
so I exactly know I mean I just could
have had to get to place where it's like
sometimes I'll go out to eat dinner with
my family and there's not much I can
choose from but it's like that's what
they do and they're the majority so I
just like I'll either eat something
ahead of time so that I could have like
you know something like a salad or
something that easy but I think there
should be compromise I don't think you
should be required to only go to
places that he likes eat and there's
also good like Asian places do a lot of
good like food where you could at least
go like where he could go and have like
tofu in it and not you Piper there's
lots of vegan on a Thai place right I
was going to say like Thai and Indian
Chinese is a little bit harder but yeah
even Japanese I mean there's options you
can get so I think he could make some
compromises so that you could have how
funny would it be if like we go to these
vegan places and then I like postmates
meat over the run Johnny K Mads I'm like
I'm gonna just post me and barbeque yeah
I just like your sauce Oh
the vegan sauce so it would you date a
vegan Jennifer
you wouldn't even date one really I
couldn't relate hurting injury eating
three times a day so it's like three
times they were not we're to go to
several places well I you not to eat
every meal with the person you're dating
how many you want everything like
seriously dude okay you so much fun I'm
talking about dating Ashley dating
smashing well like going out of once or
twice a week
that's like smashing that's casual
dating smashing you know I don't know
what like let's eat something that match
by are you serious yeah I date I don't I
do
you could also date and not do things
that are centered around food though
wait a minute time out you're just
smashing in an eating
that's real dating but if you go out and
then you fog smash I'm trying not to be
the that's not yeah you're gonna get
you're gonna go eat can we talk about
this okay I'm so glad you brought this
up this is the topic I wanted to talk
about today the outer nose
okay here's I want to talk about so I
want to talk about the difference
between casual dating serious dating and
what Jack is calling smashing with food
okay which by the way is called
squashing other that's a whole other
thing
so alright I'm gonna tell you guys
what's up with me and then I want you to
weigh in on how you can relate to this
okay so I've been talking to this guy
for a few months just talking though we
we aren't dating definitely then we
started hooking up okay now this guy I'm
telling him he says it's casual which
I'm like cool
casual is fine if you keep it casual
meaning for me if I casually date you
what I expect is like you hit me up when
you want to hang we make a plan we do it
in between then occasional text is cool
but you know that's it it's wearing a
casual you don't ask me who else I'm
seeing you'll ask me one who has dinner
with last night right it's all just
don't I don't tell okay basically that's
the policy right now it's in all that
but I don't he called with benefits
it's a you had a man Colin are you
dinner like it's like we call 2017 like
it's like no we're people let's make
sure also hang out and not necessarily
have sex yeah I don't think so maybe
it's come on okay if you're meeting this
person once a week you're gonna have sex
with this person right um well I was I
wanted to see you horse a week we're
gonna have sex if I'm just getting meals
out of it I'm not [ __ ] you
necessarily so we're not [ __ ] well
here's the thing I mean initially when I
start seeing anyone okay unless it
starts out as sex meaning like we meet
once we have great chemistry I know it's
not going to be dating we have sex then
that turns in typically for me to a
booty call
which means in my definition of a booty
call
there's no food involved unless we order
and after the cell yeah I feel booty
call is very much like what are you
doing like yeah eleven twelve o'clock at
night and it's very sane it's like I'm
super horny I really want to have sex
right yeah I mean well people have
options yeah yeah so I mean to me that's
a booty call now like what you're saying
like if I start hanging out with a guy
and I don't sleep with them right away
and we're doing dinners or whatever and
then eventually I have sex with them
then most likely after that I'm probably
going to have sex with them most of the
time we hang out unless I'm like
some reason I can't like I just got my
period or which there's still options
I'm okay with it but some guys aren't so
you shower before a plethora that's
another topic that I love them like I'll
be your tampons dad are you gonna pull
out this tampon by the strings I've got
a little bit I like that that's kinky on
a whole nother life I don't do it on day
one but day - after I'm so down Yeah
right
and if a guy isn't into it I kind of am
like I don't know if he's relationship
material even hitman early Heian
honestly but okay so so booty call for
you jack could meet could include meals
yeah I mean like booty calls had to be
at night they could be like hey you want
to listen eat it just respectable what
we call like it's like I I care about
you a little bit but I don't want to be
with you that's whether you're some food
to me not in the cattle to me that's
casual dating yeah I mean like casual
date if I'm casually dating though if I
guess I was casually dating a lot of
people yeah you can though that's what
makes it casual right I don't know I
will my jacket afraid you guys if you
like listening Jacko's frightened by
this cover section make some calls
no but like you are a relationship guide
you're always in a relationship but when
you're not if you're having meals and
sex with multiple women to me or
casually dating all those women Oh with
just children especially because you're
eating I don't know it depends I guess
if you're I guess if you start asking
questions like hey what are you doing
were you doing last night then it
becomes dating because you're actually
getting into each other's but aren't you
not ask that one a stranger she depends
okay as you look a little dating game
you don't confuse it I just think with
casual dating there's like different
elements in it because like you can
casually date and you don't I mean you
could go and go hiking together or you
can go and like watch a movie like I
don't feel like you have to at least if
I'm casually dating I'm usually not
sleeping with that person because I
probably if I'm casually dating you I'm
not thinking in terms of long-term so
I'm just thinking like I'm trying to get
a meal and everything's out of it
wait so I own it as a date even if
there's no intention for sex sex every
woman I don't mean it different you're
special I know it's early but all of
them but it but I I don't count as a
date unless there's a way if we kiss to
me it's a date if we don't kiss it's not
a date it's just like hanging out as
friends and that's where I differentiate
in my head I think every time baby not
kiss guys but I think after state okay
I've got a lot of first date because I
get really bored easily so usually on
the first date I just I think of it like
a serial casual dater cuz I just keep on
going on a bunch of first day so I'm
like thanks for the meal okay it's a
date if it's a first date and you don't
kiss but I guess what I'm saying is
after the first date like if I hang out
with you three four or five times and
there's no kissing
then to me I'm like weirdest friends
that's to you I think every guy thinks
it's a date no matter what really we
have to pay because yeah you're a local
girl
I mean it's a date but see I was I was
going out with this guy and we went out
like four times or something before he
kissed me thought it was a date no and
then I said to him I feel like we could
see that how would you define us and I
said I guess like casually dating but
not together and then he said I don't
consider myself to be dating anyone so
I've had sex with them and I go them
what do you call it when you take a girl
out pay for the meal and kiss her at the
end and he goes I don't know meetup
amigo amigo I've never heard that term
like wait up it's confusing he was what
does that mean he was white oh right
yeah he's wedding I'd only people color
you let's go meet up I know that term I
just to me it's like if the guy pays and
he kisses you at the end even if it's a
kiss on the cheek if there's a moment of
like romance
for me it's a date if he buys nachos
it's a date that's it can I have dated
Fabri comedy club manager continent no
all right so so to you this is the
reason I'm bringing this up because so
then all right so I've been hanging out
with Jude for awhile but we did have a
commerce
station where we're like this isn't
going to have a label he's like I don't
really want a relationship I'm like okay
we can keep it casual until we can write
so I've been trying really hard to keep
it casual see other people keep doing my
thing right but then this guy he texts
me every day Oh a lot not like once like
hey how's your day like every day every
night like wanting to talk talk just
like keeping the conversation going you
know like all the time usually unless
he's busy
and then he wait and then he I only get
a hobby she always tells me what he's
doing like you know what you're dating
someone seriously and they're always
telling you like oh I'm going to I'm
going to do this with my buddy Jack like
they'll name it it's a guy so you know
what he's got like updates right so he
does that and then he'll ask me things
like I'll say I went to dinner last
night and he'll go I'll say I had an
amazing steak last night no go who'd you
go to dinner with or like when I was in
Vegas he was like so did you hook up
like Sarah he's either controlling like
no he would not or just nosy well and
then I said to him this is what this is
what I want to know so I said to him cuz
I would know if I'm crazy I said to him
listen if you want to keep it casual we
can do that but you got to keep it
casual
right I've never dated someone casually
that asked me did you hook up in Vegas
who'd you have dinner with really soon
no oh those [ __ ] are crazy
hey wait what are you I know dating
casually with a Middle Eastern guy but
but so then I said that to him and then
he goes I'm just asking I don't care I
just curious you can he goes I don't
know who these guys are that you usually
date that are like I think it's a big
deal if you hook up in Vegas you have
dinner with someone else and you made it
sound like I'm crazy for thing why not
casual I just kind of feel like why you
asking because if it is casual he
shouldn't be asking those questions it
should be your life of your life right
and then his life is his life unless
he's into that and he goes how many
that's what I said I'm like maybe he
gets turned on by it like some guys are
into that if you tell them right I don't
know tell me I mean I just like I don't
care if I'm dating if I'm sleeping with
you whether it's casual whether you're a
booty call whatever the situation is I'm
not going to tell you about another guy
that I'm seeing or that I yeah that's so
easier unless you are like unless you
say like can I watch you with someone
else and I know you're a freak and I
know it's yours but I wouldn't date a
guy that wants to watch me or someone
else I think it's weird so I'm not crazy
this is weird any weird and you know
it's not like he's like one of those
guys that'll confuse you because you'll
be like oh he keeps texting me and he
checks in he's asking on these questions
and so it'll like blur that line and so
it's kind of like if we're going to keep
it casual like don't ask me these
questions because it is it's none of his
business if it's just when we're
together we hang out together and we're
apart were apart and there's no
commingling of anything then he
shouldn't be asking anything like that
because you're not asking him those
questions no care I don't care I just
bored and ISM she's not bored
yeah I mean the thing is I said to him I
go I don't ask you anything
I don't even when I'm dating someone
casually I don't even ask them questions
about their career their family to me
it's like your life is your business and
anything you want to tell me you will
but I don't ask people like you know did
you get that promotion to do because to
me it's like this is casual so what do
you talk about meeting and smashing
mister you lay here and then you hide X
yeah but if it just like take some more
ketchup and then yeah if it's just
eating and smashing but thank you Jack
that's accurate
why all the tags I don't know maybe
you're just why are guys so crazy over
you they are no usual a golden ticket
vagina I don't know all right well I'm
just trying to figure this [ __ ] out but
in the meantime then you know while I'm
trying to like I was trying to keep it
really casual and then all this kind of
happened and then I kind of tried to
talk about it which I hate
I hate talking about feelings and stuff
and then and then when I tried to talk
about it then he totally thought I was
crazy for thinking this isn't that I did
using lexing and he was putting his on
you I think he was trying to like be
like oh you're the one oh this person no
did you comment No
plead the fifth you don't know what oh
there's someone else but but anyway so
the point I'm trying to make is if
you're doing a casual situation I just
think that you got to keep it casual
because once the lines get blurred it's
hard to go backwards and now we've kind
of gone past where it's casual but
what's funny is I was starting to feel
like I want this to be like a real thing
because the way he's acting
but then we had this talk and you're
like no this is my version of casual it
really made me like shut down because in
my head I go oh well then does that mean
he treats every girl like this which
means there could be like 20 more I'm
yeah whatever he likes control or he
just likes to feel like he has like 40
girlfriends like a Mormon husband so
then that made me pull back and then it
just so happened literally the day after
we had this talk this super hot guy that
I was kind of interested in just
happened to call me and was like let's
kick it and I was like maybe this is
some kind of like whatever it is like
fate or whatever stepping in to be like
no no no you this shouldn't be a serious
thing talk to other people I felt like
it was a sign it probably was yeah I
definitely think it was but I do have a
question yeah free and I want your
opinion I want to ask you Jack ferns
okay what is up with because you got to
mention this kick it hanging out like if
I haven't gone on a date with you
dislike let's hang out like what does
that mean when a guy that means I want
to have sex with you but I don't want
you to know yet I want to build your
confidence will you trust me and then
when you're ready I'm ready
but then why okay if that's what it is I
najeev why not try to have a date like
why not ask me on a date where I secure
anything you're going to say no right
away so he could rather build you up as
a friend as I've done this that's what
it means
was my because you'll feel threatened
would let's hang our yeah hang out what
if I say you want to go on ticularly
whoa my fee let's hang out I kind of get
more info on you and then just break
your wall and then break your well and
then case of that all right Angela
brought to you by where okay so you
eventually asked for the date no so I
just become saying out not to like
but wait well I think when a guy says
hang out then to me that's his way of
saying right up front this is cash this
is like I'm just trying to hang like I
just want to hook up I don't want what
time was the time wrong let's hang out
one no these are like day times really
like let's hang out but I'm come on you
know but you don't really don't they
don't really know like I mean people
that I kind of know to like strangers be
like oh let's hang out and I'm like
Ranger that's actually a homeless guy at
seven lobbies like oh people you meet
out and you they're like you exchanged
numbers okay and so today let's hang out
to me I'm kind of like either you're
gonna ask me out on a date or I'm not
going to get really does it I don't want
a date yeah what do you want them to say
on men what is the proper way to older
these men yeah okay old fries I mean I
forgot I mean like can I take you on a
date if a guy said to me like when are
we hanging out I think that means he's
asking me out on a date unless it's a
guy that I've been I'm already pals with
but if like a guy don't know is like
well I mean I guess sometimes I'll say
like I'd love to get let's go out for
drinks or something I mean here's what I
tend to date older men so like how old
am i scary and read feelings
do they have walkers no like I know you
may I take you wanna date do you have a
family about being banged up against a
walker
negative no like I would say like late
thirties to like mid 40s so late
thirties older like old are you 32 the
forties order absolutely like about
50-60 Oh
I'm not talking like elderly leg order
than you yeah all right like so but with
it I mean I tend to get men that will be
like oh I would like to see you and
spend time with you like are you
available for dinner
that sounds loud I read he's giving you
a schedule he's like I'm free for dinner
guy you took me out on the best date I
ever had just just not that date like
most fun but best date that was like the
most proper that was like I really want
to take you somewhere nice and he took
me in a great car to an amazing
restaurant and spent all this money and
like no but he turned out to be married
I didn't know but I'm saying jack is
right I think when they like when they
put on the full-court press like that
the reason why you have to censor the
movie I mean that's funny so like if
they just messaged you and say like can
I buy you dinner does that count or do
they have to actually say the word date
in it well I mean like if you have a
plan like open fire than that know that
will creep me out I'd be like are you on
the 50s right yeah I like fish shovelry
I'd like old school like I like come
with the plan when you want to hang out
I don't want to [ __ ] hang out no you
and I agree I agree with that like I
really like it like I always make the
guy pick everything like when a guy is
like can I take you out I go sure what
did you have in mind and then they go
how about dinner and I'll go cool pick
the spot let me know what time I like to
let the guy I really don't want to tell
you picking and they get mad when you
pick I know guys median guys always way
that I'm not that way like I even like
the guy to order for me unless it's all
like if a guy said what kind of food you
like can I go seafood and how would you
like this I'm in house are six pieces
that has happened to me mother I mean
like I I like that stuff so I agree with
come with a plan and be a man and pick a
time and all that kind of stuff I'm just
saying the word date doesn't yeah music
I mean yeah you don't necessarily have
to put the word date but like something
very specific like I you know would like
to see you okay can we plan a day or
something like may I take it dinner or
something or may I do this like some
type of agenda not just like oh I wanted
Netflix and chill it is really hot when
guys are direct and guys are so really
too
and I think part of its insecurity but I
think part of it is like this whole
running game thing not yeah but like I
was dating a guy and I went on a trip to
Vegas actually not this time but I came
back from Vegas and and I was back two
days and I hadn't hit the guy up and one
day out of the blue he texted me and he
goes you've been back two days I want to
see you and to me that was so hot
because guys never just say like I want
to see donors worth I want to see you
it's very sexy
it's so hot because so often guys try to
act cool like it's whatever I'm chill I
don't hit you up no Urinetown and like
wait a week yeah you know who wins the
guy that lets you know he's interested
wins I don't think guys realize that
they're like I'll neg you I'll be cool
you can do that there's me another dude
that comes along who's just as hot who
lets you know I'm into you all the way
anyway listen I've been do an ad the
show's halfway over and I all right guys
last week I didn't ad for our X bar and
this is very important
I [ __ ] up [ __ ] up the ad so first of
all I do want to say this I really
[ __ ] love our X bars
I probably shouldn't swear in my ads I
don't know how that is going to be so
real I start this again
guys I'm kidding we're not cutting
anything I really do love to rx bars if
you guys tried these have you had an Rx
or oh no no oh my god they're so good I
know I should have brought some their
protein bars are made from egg whites
all that's in them there's like no
chemicals
I hate chemical stuff I used to eat
other protein bars with chemicals and it
would always break out my face oh yeah
this stuff is amazing it's literally egg
whites dates almonds and then like
whatever flavor you like like they have
like chocolate coconut they have all the
peanut butter ons are so good I'm
addicted em I want to tennis today so I
really do love them I want you guys to
get them where I messed up as I forgot
to give you the discount code so I told
you if you go to our x-bar dot-com
backslash date fails you can get 25% off
but you do have to put in the promo code
which is date fails so make sure you
guys visit our x-bar calm backslash
state fails promo code date fails at
checkout
they're gluten free soy free dairy free
no added sugar no artificial colors I
mean they're literally egg white state
nuts and flavor they're so good
I want I've been eating so many actually
I'm kind of not sure that's why you're
saying this maybe like I'm not sure what
the limit is on how many you should eat
but uh I came home from Vegas there was
a box of them that at my front door and
I'm in it there was no other food in my
house so I ate like half the box so
anyway guys make sure you go to our X
bar comm backslash date bails and enter
that discount code date bails
yeah I didn't add now I feel really good
about that now we're going to go back to
talking about dates as well so I don't
know if we actually figured out what is
casual and what is not in it we have
internet out with casually different for
women and then for a minute it could be
yeah maybe that I don't know um here's
something else I want to talk about I
was just in Vegas and I forgot about I I
can't believe I've never told this story
on here do you ever have a moment where
you remember a story of something you
did that you're like why have I never
talked about this on stage or anywhere
that remind you eight years ago
haha no my god all right sometimes you
have to push out of your memory I think
that that's what happened I deleted this
my brain this is the worst date fail I
ever had and I can't believe I forgot it
so I long story short I was in Vegas one
time and I was with friends who were
athletes and whatever and there was a
guy at our table heard about a club and
this guy is like [ __ ] hot very
famous the hottest it would be like if
you [ __ ] Halle Berry or Brad Pitt like
this level of like hotness why'd you
look at me with Brad Pitt okay so all
right so I'm out with these guys and
that and this guy's hitting on me and
I'm like I can't believe this guy's
hitting on me like I'm like he's so hot
I'm like this kit I must be really
buzzed or something okay
really happening he's flirting and
flirting and so in my head I was like I
don't ever have like one-night stand and
I don't ever hook up with guys because
they're like famous and I like I'm not
about that but in this one circumstance
I was like you can't not this would be
if how it very was like listen we do in
this you don't do it you're a [ __ ] yeah
oh yeah yeah I need that life story
right so I decided I'm gonna do this so
but I was like a little nervous oh so I
had a key extra of tequila shot or two
and then I left with him and we went up
to his hotel room organized yeah yes
sweet yes we go to his room we hook up
sex is so good the sex is like super hot
he's great in bed I was actually
surprised because I assumed every famous
person will be bad in bed they usually
are honestly they're lazy [ __ ]
like the all the guys I talked to our
famous which is not a lot but the few
are not good in bed
so uh this guy's great and he didn't
even I don't think he took anything and
he [ __ ] me like three times like he
came like three times
oh wow so this last time just we met the
first time was quicker I was so hot that
was on a balcony I walk out on a balcony
I'm overlooking like another building
that was shorter there's like a rooftop
pool and then he comes up behind me he's
like what if I just [ __ ] you on this
balcony and I'm like okay yeah it was
the best I never had sex on a balcony
before so get it so we did it there
that was didn't last too long you know
five minutes or them and then um record
time I know I know and then but then
after that the second time was like I
don't know 15 minutes did he take it one
of those power bars he ate our actors
are halfway through no they weren't
around yet but so then he does it again
and then you know and then he gets
another condom and he's like round three
and I'm like holy [ __ ] like I was
impressed right also I started to feel a
little off
I wasn't feeling
that's when I started to be like I don't
think something's not right and then and
then he we do to get and then he goes
I'm gonna grab a quick shower and then
we go in for round four and I'm like
holy [ __ ] so he goes and gets in the
shower he's in the shower and I'm like
oh my god I start to feel sick Oh
spinning Oh No like I don't know what to
do so I run in the bathroom I'm like I
think I'm gonna be sick and he's like
what he's like get to the toilet I start
puking in this thing Oh in the sink
because I couldn't make it to the toilet
I start throwing up into thinking and he
starts yelling at me don't puke in the
sink
puke in the toilet puke in the toilet
and I'm like I'm trying but I'm like
really like like what do you call like
if you like sopping hold on like I'm
rushing the toilet he starts getting mad
he's like you gotta puke in my toilet
I'm like okay so I go to run to the
toilet
halfway to the toilet I can't keep it in
and I puke all over the bathroom just
everywhere do you have any like a pool I
had eaten like a salad there like gross
oh sorry everywhere and then I get to
the toilet key puking and then he's like
what the [ __ ] you've done his shoes Oh
Jordans yeah I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know that's partially as well he
shouldn't let your puke in the sink you
could have just rinsed it out got a
little soap and it would have been done
it would have been fine because the
hotel your housekeeping yeah he's like
it's gonna smell and all the [ __ ] so
then so then I finished puking in the
toilet and then by then he's out of the
shower and he is like disgusted I'm a
cute ocean if you [ __ ] Halle Berry and
you what if you're like round 400 in my
mind it was like I blew it I'm never
going to be able to [ __ ] this guy again
I was so upset but then then it gets
worse then he's like get in my shower
you're dicover I puke on my leg like I
was so good
again the shower turns it on like
ice-cold water I'm like I'm so cold he's
like it's going to sober you up my can't
think it is I start to like I'm like I
think I'm gonna pass out please get down
so I I laid down on the shower floor
naked cold water splashing on me like I
can't imagine what I must look like oh
my god I forget because it literally one
of those things I would have tried to
like forget and just factory reset in my
brain I think I've blocked it out
because it was so embarrassing and then
I was having a baby they knew yeah
possession know what I call in Vegas
this last time I was hanging out with
another friend who's a really hot famous
guy and I was thinking about banging him
and it reminded me of what happened the
last time oh my god I was like I'm not
doing it I was all over it how did it
end though you're in the shower I don't
know about this is hello Bugsy yeah so
I'm in the shower
so I basically fall asleep he says to
Talam but the towel is small because he
had used all the big towels to clean up
the puke so he threw like a hand so I'm
like covered like it naked on this guy's
bathroom floor or shower floor water
running still the boys and then not he's
like you know I gotta get up early I'm
gonna try and sleep a little bit but
just call me if you need anything here's
a bucket they put the bucket next to me
oh and just let you sit in the shower I
couldn't get up I was like have you ever
been so drunk that you're I stand up I'm
gonna [ __ ] some Atari so I fall
asleep kind of but I'm still like kind
of dry heaving and like making noises
like moaning so then I start hearing
pounding on the door and he's like fog
she's like Security's at the door I'm
like what he's like you were kind of
like moaning in your sleep I think
someone called security I go to open the
door and tell mom okay he's like he's
[ __ ] gone she's like I got a white
girl pass out by naked in my shower I'd
open in the door and I was like I was
like I
I don't know what to do it's like you
got to get out of here I'm like I don't
know what to do it's like you got to get
out of here we gotta call your cab Oh
so I'm like alright so I get up at this
point I like stop puking and then he
called me a cab and then I got in the
cab and I left and then I never I never
talked to him pre-k movie did I really
not all about it till I was in Vegas
this last time and I was thinking of
hooking up with that guy and I was like
I don't know but that guy it's going to
be I can't believe I never told the
story on a machine that is mortifying
I like mortified for you have you ever
thrown up on anybody you had that I'm
very good about a girl we had one time
shut off like full-on like like and I
was like oh what happened are you
serious what does she bust your teeth in
it came back oh it wasn't it to win it
yeah that's not a big deal I'm sorry yes
it is hey throwing up on you is
embarrassing but I mean like she's
giving you head yeah
that is gross though I hopefully
wouldn't go back I would've been just
like I'm sorry like you wouldn't go back
hell no my tea I would if I hadn't got
off yet I feel like mouthwash baby bug
leave the bag let's go I am so bad do
you think after this episode that I'm
never going to get laid again because
you're hot and so lost you there's a
check in with you throughout the evening
like yes can you please don't water
exactly I think this is Aaron Aaron do
you think this is the reason guys don't
think I'm relationship material it could
be all right Cheryl what's the grossest
thing you've ever done then what's the
worst thing I had a similar experiences
that would make one what what happened I
was dating this years ago
um I was dating someone and I we okay so
at the time that day I hadn't really
eaten anything so we got we smoked and I
had had a little drink at the same time
and I
got really high and at that time I used
to smoke weed I don't really I don't
smoke anymore but at that time I used to
consistently smoke weed and so I got
really high to the point where I was
like I don't think this is like the
normal high like I don't know because I
didn't eat or there's something in it
but I was like pins and needles in my
hands and like time was moving slow like
I was having like an outer-body
experience so I got scared and because I
didn't know if I was drugged so I locked
myself in a bathroom and call the cops
where is this at the guy's house has the
guy's house how well did you know this
guy like this was like our second time
hanging out they were really dating yet
you know yeah I do
it was either our second or third time a
house so we had gone to dinner and like
everything was cool and I was just like
oh yeah like smoke Allah times like oh
it should be okay and I lost myself in
the bathroom and I called the cops I
didn't know if I was drugs and I didn't
want to like lay down because I was like
I don't know like I was like if I lay
down he may try something there was
other people over there and I didn't
know that other people oh so I was just
like I got really paranoid and then I
end up like having a full-blown panic
attack and called the police
I was really well eventually so the
police came and like he came with an
ambulance and so they like they like
they will first look guy was trying to
get me out of the bathroom he was like I
could come out of course I was afraid
then this girl I hear she goes um like
tell her to cut him out I'm going to cut
that [ __ ] and I was like oh I'm
definitely not leaving the mask now so
I'm like terrified because I'm already
paranoid so let's guy must have thought
you were a psychopath by the way if all
y'all get to smoke a little weed and
you're like I'm calling a bullet and no
like I'm terrified to leave the bathroom
so finally the police come and then I
don't believe it's them so then I make
them slide their badge underneath the
crack in the door and then it was
actually them I really call sooner ha ha
and they're like ok well this a white
guy or a black guy it was a black guy it
wasn't that would be so funny if it was
a white guy and it was like the reverse
of what happened here so I can't call
the police a black woman
hi break it out in my bath like no
you'll be fine you look like a scientist
they're gonna probably take your word
over mine all gone yeah and so
eventually the Qods cave and I like put
me on a stretcher and like I like we
drugged yeah what were you all know I
mean they cut in my went to the hospital
I couldn't be like couldn't find
anything modern system so yeah I might
have been PC me you think yeah they were
on a drug test on your they did do a
drug test at the hospital but like they
said that they weren't able to find many
shoes the tail or there's like a really
give them demons I had at that time I
like not go along before and so it was
like I never like even when I've gotten
really high ones before I just got sick
like it was her did you eat an edible
was anything out I had just smoked and
then he and Amy I had alcohol with maybe
that's it
so I know it's just but it was like
something don't smoke or drink with her
ever that was literally my hands around
like I like I like quit cold-turkey I
was like I'm never smoked let me ask you
a question if the guy had called the
hangout a date specifically would it
have bothered you as bad when you got
high I mean probably I mean I still
thought I was doing drugs so I don't
know everyone I was on a date like then
it's just like what is I can't believe
that happened but I actually end up
seeing and they did like we end up
talking after we saw we were never yeah
I brought you with my baby mama I was
surprised than average every bit so we
don't still saw each other after that
smash yes we did it laughter did you
date or smash this ooh yeah
I'm like fascinated by this whole dating
and smashing with food conversation I I
got to figure this out I'd like to know
your guys at home what you think about
casual dating versus whatever the [ __ ]
what do you think casual dating is yeah
when does it become as it exists or is
this something Kate made up no it is
anything yeah well your definition is in
the casually division especially my
definition of casual casual dating
yeah good my definition of casual dating
is smashing and eating uh not just
eating I could spray I could casually
date two or three guys and what that
would mean to me is like it doesn't have
to be just smashing and eating we could
I could go out of town for a weekend
with a guy we could take a trip but if
we're not exclusive
as long as there's no label where this
is an exclusive relationship I could go
on a trip with you one weekend and on
the trip was reason okay so this is
according to Wikipedia oh wow oh the
special definition of casual Dame was
just a casual dating or a casual
relationship is a physical and emotional
relationship between two people who may
have casual sex or near sexual
relationship without necessarily
demanding or expecting the extra
commitment of a more formal romantic
relationship casualties or casual
relationships very they say multiple
relationships it doesn't say anything
about that's your definition so we're
going to smash and smash smash smash but
it says we don't expect anything of the
other person meaning they're allowed to
the whole look the only reason to be
dating you just smash it because it's
are you intruders okay well you're
dating someone let's say you're dating
that's getting Bob and you meet me at a
show and you're like oh this is Bob were
casually dating I wouldn't say that what
would you say I would say this is Bob my
friend I wouldn't say friend or anything
I know this is Bob and he was like yeah
I won't answer I will say this I when I
talk about guys that I casually date
okay if I'm talking to a girl I'll say
this guy I've been kind of seeing but if
I'm talking to another guy that I'm
interested in I'll say my friend so I
might call like four guys that I'm
dating my friend two other guys yeah I'm
not going to say like if I'm kind of
interested in going out with you and I
was with another guy on a date the other
night I might be like oh the other night
I was with my friend at this restaurant
and I wouldn't say yeah this guy I'm
dating so I guess I don't know but but
you can whatever this is this so our
definitions are similar in that day that
destination
yeah it's just it's smashing and food is
casual dating
so what happens if you aren't smashing
but it's casually just a friend
oh no we're getting a free meal sure
whatever what I believe making out with
people like I'm leaving actually dating
I wish are all on this and I do think
there's a difference in guys and girls
because to me I can be dating you and
we're not having sex yet if it is I know
it's leading towards that in my mind and
every time it's getting like I would be
so mad though after hearing your pas
together he smashed everybody how could
you this mess
I don't smash everything everybody but
I'm saying like if we started really a
long time how often do I have casual sex
for real with just like randoms that I
told you about oh honey not many yeah
because I mean I guess like I thought I
was casually dating people but like I
mean I wasn't actually having sex with
them out of just maybe and maybe I was
just hanging out okay what kind of dates
what kind of guys you like um I tend to
like business types I didn't like like
like I mentioned like slightly like
later 30s mid 40s I tended like very
much business type men um business like
legal no yeah I had construction you
know like that like own businesses or
lawyers or whatever people that have
like come on ambition for a dude like
yeah I mean I want to ring do you want
to get married eventually to those that
you want to get married like but not no
actually I don't want to get better
tomorrow that's one thing about me I've
never actually like wanted to get
married young I've always wanted to get
married later in life and I'm guys later
in life so that's actually not a driving
force but like casual dating I do know
instantaneously from meeting someone
whether or not I would ever have sex
with them and so usually oh yeah you got
to get that legal but we will do with
then no you guys don't really have to go
do they hear the head lice tweeted a
joke once I worry that I know within 10
minutes of [ __ ] someone whether or
not I'd want to date that not the other
way around
and now I'm like I can't visualize it it
won't happen
Wow I don't know I mean
guess I know sometimes I meet someone I
know right away I want to [ __ ] them but
sometimes I meet someone and then I'm
like I don't know if I'd want to but
then after a couple times hanging now
that's what the category I followed ah
jab like give me like a date like let's
hang out weird you know what's weird
this guy I've been hanging with recently
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call it
when I first met him
we had like this instant chemistry which
he's not the type I typically am into
but we had this instant chemistry where
right away I was like I think we'd have
really good sex I could just feel it and
typically when I feel that the guy is
like complete garbage and it's really
hoc sick and everything about the whole
whatever it is it ends up being terrible
but this guy's actually I can tell he's
actually a nice guy and internally I'm
struggling like why am I so attracted to
him I'm not a man [ __ ] that's not me
usually chemically my body only wants
you if you're like really bad for me
this might mean I'm her oh man I'm
growing during I think I'm yeah Dadar
I'm just in my 30s and I just really
horny I don't know what it is but well I
think I think I feel like we've uh we
talked about talked about a lot and
we're ready start recording yeah yeah
better than last week last week's
episode Aaron I don't know if you heard
this I recorded 20 minutes of the
podcast and then realized I never hit
record
so we lost like 20 minutes of the
podcast so that's why Aaron needs to be
here to produce this yeah yeah all right
listen we're going to get off here but I
want you guys to give shout outs to
whatever you got going on charelle you
go first okay sure I'll the trees
instagram twitter facebook at CH ER e ll
e PA TR IC e at Cheryl Patrice if you're
on Instagram definitely follow me there
I do a lot of comedy skits on there so I
will guarantee you to make you laugh
okay yeah I'm going to be in Texas
Phoenix
New York New Jersey
and all the dates are on my website Jack
Jr comics calm or with my Instagram Jack
jr. comic I'll be with Kate in Phoenix
Arizona come check us out over there I
know a lot of fans at Phoenix I listen
to your podcast so come check us out all
right yay and I will be next weekend
in Edmonton with Brian Redman at the
comic strip the following weekend will
be a house of comedy Minneapolis make
sure you guys come out you can get
tickets on the website red band will be
with me in Minneapolis as well and I did
want to say for the people supporting on
patreon I'm about to redo the patreon so
it's going to be different it's just
going to be one price and I'm going to
put bonus episode of the podcast up
there so if you love the podcast make
sure you hop on patreon supports
patreon.com backslash KQ funny I love
you guys so much thanks for following
make sure you subscribe to all the all
things comedy podcasts and we'll see you
next time
[Music]